I think this has been by far the most
complex yeah we haven't had anything
like this this is crazy in depth we're
gonna have to take it back to that other
room use that to water the plant use the
vine to climb up get the torch go in the
other room light up the spiderweb oh
this my end is this what I party all
right Luigi we can go up to level eight
now
paranormal productions yo this looks
pretty cool
Weegee still terrified no surprise no
surprise oh man this floor looks cool
this look at this oh it's just your
Thomas oh my goodness that I know chris
tolly knows the inspiration for this
poster
all we had to do was welcome to the TV
are you serious right now
yet another new mechanic in this game
guys and that was he in there all along
that wasn't gold okay is this what I see
this is what happens are see you like oh
my goodness that is not expected now see
the question is what's the purpose of
the TV here there must eventually
there's gonna be a need for us to travel
back and forth I'm guessing Oh green
screen this case blue screen effects
whoops
sorry duck man wouldn't you love it if
you could just kick a barrel and money
would pop out I mean wouldn't that make
the world just an easier place would you
look at this oh it's got a gym over here
RC oh and the megaphone Luigi look that
must be the megaphone looks like it's
trapped in some spinal waves those must
be haughty webs hold your breath chat I
don't know what's gonna come out of here
or don't know nothing okay
I was little teen cyclomatic does this
show up in there what in the world yo
okay GUI G inside oh this is awesome d
wow this is actually this is actually
pretty difficult man to figure out I
feel like cuz I just kind of got lucky
that I had Luigi in the shot
aw dude he's got a fight that goes
really well we're just trying to put out
the fire man I feel like we're the kind
of the bad guy in the situation guys I
mean it maybe it's just me but we got
him is that it I did it
she'll be able to finally pick up our
block of ice walk over here no dude this
looks like something at a toy story man
no one's ever attempted a bypass brain
transplant before Betty right no no no
no
[Music]
oh that did that look like that did some
damage man try this again I didn't do
anything right they're burning away the
web's you'd need some fire for that
exactly dude uh-oh another cutscene fire
okay if we can be getting closer to this
dude if there are stairs in there and
it's just like the cameras screwing up
I'm gonna be so mad come on make it grow
please all right again okay let's just
this is crazy dude let's just okay this
is number two let's just go one by one
okay this one didn't trigger any kind of
cutscene or anything no you guys noticed
that until I pushed the X button that is
[Music]
we have this level that there seems to
be no way to solve Oh is there something
we can do to set this guy on fire we
have been stuck on this here level this
here level we've been stuck on it for a
while even if this doesn't work I feel
like this is I feel like this is on the
right track is that kept on fire though
no it's not I'm going crazy now though
dude I'm going crazy like I'm having all
these memories of other rooms like there
was water and there was fire and there
was this and there was a spider and
there was that and then we did this and
then and it doesn't work okay a giant
rock comes over breaks that yeah and
then it shows you the vine like look
here use the vine bring water dude if it
is that hey it's down in there oh my
gosh and when the dude emerges when the
dude emerges he's gonna be holding the
water please please
well come on
this is not a kids game dude what kid
would put all this together yes this is
crazy in depth we're gonna have to take
it back to that other room use that to
water the plant use the vine to climb up
get the torch go in the other room light
up the spiderweb no yes
water that plan okay set it down do not
touch my water you punks
don't even think about it get away from
the water dude I don't even want to slam
them over here
slam them over here away from the water
Luigi you thought you could bring us
down you thought you could stop retro
wreck and tore his tab we're wrong you
need its torch as my reward
dude it's even more big brain man like
the fire goes out I'm gonna have to take
it to the room with the fire I think
this has been by far the most complex
yeah we haven't had anything like this
so far yeah that's what I'm talking
about I can't believe the just one
little item dude when you've got the
Yeti head you've got the you've got the
night helm all these other items and
it's the little cap to the bottle we've
got
oh we can torch the spider let's go wow
man I feel like a freakin genius and you
should to check go give him his silly
megaphone all right here you go pal
celebrate yo
[Music]
and we can use that to sitting back you
can pull it back at him though
oh it's fighting back though excellent
excellent keep it up
oh man tell me switch it up whoa I don't
know what that one is I'm gonna send
that one back get him No
we need help we need GUI G we needs a
double power to send it back
got it
[Music]
a chance to achieve stardom
yo look at this
the QTE
then we got him and with that ladies and
gentlemen we have conquered level 8 of
Luigi's Mansion 3 and it was a doozy
let me tell you